no I'm angry ozone I'd love to be
grateful for like like it was a good
time you know we had a lot of fun down
there and you know heavy third album
would you know what I get in our Studios
ahold of a situation it's kind of lamb
[Music]
filming Kravitz cradle to the grave in
LA you know I was coming over songs and
songs I was going to the CEO after I
would finish filming so Joe Silva got a
studio bus which he put on the movie lot
you know I have to film and we'd go ride
the bus you know
big toys out and I decided to hit songs
because you know right wrong like I
wanted for the movie and then that's
gonna give us you that song was gonna be
on my fifth album but he's like I need
it for the movie I like I [ __ ] he's
like I'm gonna shoot the video and all
that and I said well well I can do the
soundtrack you could have the song for
the movie I got the soundtrack so we get
this over the movie it's all good but I
did wanted for my album I got a huge
weight on my shoulders I'm saying I'm
responsible for my music you know I'm
saying it and each album has to do many
things many things I'll take that
consideration as I'm recording I don't I
don't think that responsibility lightly
[Music]
house was beat first record and I was
one of the fastest on that road I wrote
it about 15 minutes and I actually
didn't want to write it I don't want to
do that song beat was simple and
repetitive you mean and the floor I came
over just like 70 of the songs with so
much substance I was like the song is
like like [ __ ] ABC's like elementary
[ __ ] gonna tired he's gonna die I'm
glad I did do it you know
I listened this was like you'll just do
it did you do this right and it worked
out I wrote two other songs that same
night I wrote a [ __ ] with D and let me
fly that same night so it was like all
right I can do this all right
all right you want it yeah all right I
would never revisit it because I mean we
did a remix to it but I wouldn't do
another version of it because it is his
own thing
now wise idea you know we always you
know we're funk with the hood anyway
y'all say oh we got to get the Pyke's in
there and do this it on my I know let's
do it that was my second video you know
the first video get at me dogs in the
tunnel crazy I mean they go we got taken
to the streets all right let's do it let
me see that was the third album in Miami
recorded enjoyed and the earth what
would that be forgot he brought me that
beat they were almost finished without
him he's like y'all I got the [ __ ]
pig before you and so they put on like
oh come on dad it's crazy just like they
yeah I wrote that kind of fast to like
it was a good time you know we had a lot
of fun down there and heavy third album
would you know what I get in our Studios
ahold of a situation it's like [ __ ] you
suck my dick [ __ ] pictures take I'll
kill you like it's kind of lamb
[Music]
sometimes people want to feel worse you
mean they don't always want to feel
better Late Late Late however the [ __ ]
you in the field there should be a song
that helps you feel that way those in
and you could just ride to and then you
know just feel like you want to feel who
the [ __ ] wants to be happy all the time
you can take advantage of always happen
nobody thinks there is happy all that
[Music]
no that was second to last song I did on
my third album yeah I'm thinking album
is done they taken Swiss was just
[ __ ] beat em I love my god this [ __ ]
is crazy right right yeah I thought you
know was it what what's my name and then
he hit me would put in Swiss hit me with
party up and I was like bananas you know
and I feel like I had something to prove
to I mean because at that point I was
the only artist in history and their
first two albums debut at number one and
I have to plan about in what year so
Mike do it again
alright like you know well [ __ ] stick
is the chocolate I'm gonna show you
something
I'm gonna show you something took me 13
years to get a [ __ ] I'm wrecking deal
you know you go usually more than a
couple hours out of me well for 100 make
it for the club the beat is for the club
I just submit some real [ __ ] to it
alright you'll give me a beat that
people could dance to I'll spit some
[ __ ] that [ __ ] beat somebody up
- it's a good combination
you kind of want the best on your music
if you're gonna do music like I yeah
excellent is they know i'ma do it
justice
I'm gonna give it a long long life it's
called party of it is very disrespectful
it's very disrespectful it feels good
that's good again it confirms nothing
I've dared to believe that it was a
night like you know my music is not just
for the moment forever
the second and last song I did on on the
grand champ hour I was also my old
friend kiddos favorite something he was
there when I recorded I did it in
Chicago when Daddy bought the beef to
Chicago and I you know I heard it I was
like immediately oh I was in love with
that people came did it you know I like
the way they revamped it it comes in and
it became something else you know like a
couple days after I recorded the song I
won't tell a and he made me out there
you know yeah when he came through he
was singing it widowhood widower
widowhood you know saying there's like
is this a you know but Chicago is all
about the hoods different neighborhoods
and you know saying you know it just it
fit I celebrate his life as he says that
a song obtains has nothing to do with
the reason why I make it well the
process that I that I that I use to me
if it blows up it blows up I know I come
from a real place when I make these
songs and I don't compromise got one of
the harshest critics of my own music
they I have to impress myself each time
so you know he still has to be better
than less